[Music]
this was supposed to be a Samsung Galaxy
fold review but it's not you know the
new Samsung foldable phone that comes
out soon and costs $2,000 I even set up
in an origami shop to show you that
phones can now fold like paper I even
learned how to make a paper butterfly I
was going to show you how awesome maps
are on the big screen and how awesome it
is to watch Netflix on the subway hmm I
know everyone wanted to be my friend
when they saw me with it but then and
then okay so those issues seem to have
nothing to do with user error but then
turns out the fold comes with a screen
protector that's not really a screen
protector it's part of the screen and if
you peel it well bad things happen to
your folding screen when I've gotten my
review unit I actually started to peel
it off but I didn't because I figured it
was a good thing to have on the crazy
thing Samsung's Galaxy S 10 models come
with screen protectors you're supposed
to take off samsung wasn't happy when
they saw a tweet of my phone with the
sticker coming off and they wanted it
back right away so you want to swap it
now so they brought me a new one the new
one looks like the old one there's still
no warning telling people who like to
peel stickers off their gadgets do not
peel the sticker off your gadget Samsung
said this in a statement the main
display on the Galaxy fold features a
top protective layer which is part of
the display structure designed to
protect the screen from unintended
scratches removing the protective layer
or adding adhesives to the main display
may cause damage we will ensure this
information is clearly delivered to our
customers sampson also explained a bit
about what's going on here see the
folding screen is made of plastic and it
can easily be scratched so it added an
extra layer of plastic to protect the
important plastic and because the extra
layer of plastic is a
attached to well plastic removing it can
disrupt the fragile electronics
underneath and that would be really
really bad still if you really want to
fold something right now fold this
or this or this or this don't buy this
and don't fold this and if you really
want to peel something peel this or this
or this not this not this all right
$2,000 phone me $2.00 hot dog hold it
[Music]